he is Ian Rapoport how are you Ian rich
how are you what's going on with
Martellus Bennett let's get straight
into it how come mother how come he's
thinking of retiring and saying that the
Packers doctor did him dirty and then
he's catching passes for Tom Brady like
it's 2016
within days what can you tell me about
unbelievable story I can't say I've ever
really seen it they like just so first
of all go back to his Packers tune so he
gets like 6 different opinions on the
shoulder and he's told by these
independent people that he needs
shoulder surgery you know so that is one
thing and then he said okay well I'm
gonna get shoulder surgery I'm gonna
retire and obviously he had played
through this when Rodgers was there now
Rodgers is not there and he says okay
I'm just gonna have surgery so he tells
the Packers and they said well you had
the surgery yeah this injury before you
came to us it's not our injury so we
can't put you on IR because he didn't
have it when he got to the Packers he
didn't he didn't do it in with the
Packers so they wave him and he tells
everyone I'm retiring don't claim me and
the Patriots say yeah cute
we'll think about it and they decided to
claim him anyway and then Bill Belichick
says just come on and play like just
play so I was in the words of Martellus
Bennett eff it
he used other words but that's basically
it so he says you know what I'm just
gonna play whatever happens to my
shoulder I'm retiring anyway so he goes
out in place and it's ridiculous so what
are the Packers gonna do about this can
they do it well they were going after
his money
they're gonna try to seek the 4.2
million dollars in prorated signing
bonus for the next two seasons and you
know to do that they're gonna need proof
that he had the injury the serious
injury torn rotator cuff before he came
to the Packers and I am told there are
tests that show that so where did the
team doctor come into play here well
what would then it says is that he had
the injury and the team doctor you know
egged him on and tried to get him to
play which is interesting because this
is dr. Mackenzie with the Packers be
notoriously cautious
overly cautious packers Doctor Who you
know battled Aaron Rodgers a couple
years back when Rodgers wanted to come
back for week 17 remember when he first
time Andrews collarbone this guy is the
most overly cautious doctor in the NFL
right now and Bennett says he egged him
on to play which of course teammates
like Aaron Rodgers and Jordy Nelson do
not exactly believe I was following all
this on Twitter and Instagram throughout
the weekend but ok so let's put that
aside and now turn to Russell Wilson's
head you know he said after the Thursday
Night Football game and he was asked all
the concussion questions that may have
happened but it didn't happen when he
was sent off the field by by the
officials on Thursday night what's the
status of this with the Seahawks and the
concussion protocol with the league yeah
I mean it may have happened but just
judging from the broadcast and for the
shots to the video that we've seen it
didn't look like it happened so just
judging from our eyes it seems like
there's on some level a breach of
protocol something now maybe there's
other views that we haven't seen maybe
there's something else that we're not
privy to but just judging from our eyes
obviously it looks like the concussion
protocol did not go as planned league
spokesman said on Sunday they're
basically starting the interview process
now something go through an interview
Wilson Seahawks medical personnel the
independent neurologist - spotter all
these people and just kind of see what
you know what happened where if they are
found in violation it could face a big
fine could lose a drastic although that
would be pretty drastic but obviously it
did not definitely did not go as planned
you can rap before joining me here on
the show by the way I have a fix to that
I'm gonna I'm gonna III have my
concussion protocol fix I'm gonna not
take up your time with it but I'll fill
you in with it when I see you next door
you can listen to it the next segment
Ian Rapoport so you got the the
concussion protocol fixed and you got
the ridiculous ball batted out of the
end zone
touch back well yeah man I mean to me
again that the the your own end zone
should not be helpful to you if you've
given up 90
maude yards that all of a sudden
somebody fumbles it into the end zone
the ball should go back to the to the
fumbly you know to the guy who's fumbled
it but again I could go on and on here
and there's a few other items I want to
hit with you here that being is is Ben
McAdoo on the chopping block like right
now the Giants normally don't act
somebody in the middle of the season but
they are one in eight and they're taking
on Andy Reed in the Chiefs and I imagine
they're gonna get they're gonna get
blown out at home again for the second
straight time what can you tell me on
this front in well he's in the building
today and he is working news to to
everyone there right so I don't sense
anything in it you know I mean the
Giants don't really do this the other
thing is if you're gonna fire your coach
midseason there's got to be a reason
right so they're not I mean I'm making
the playoffs because a fan base once
wants an answer I mean the Giants don't
lose these games they don't lose these
games like this they don't go on a road
where there's only half a stadium filled
because of the fans of seeing a windless
team in front of him and they get blown
out they don't they don't lose to the
Los Angeles Rams will be by giving up 51
points at home it was bad I mean it was
that it was all everything that's
happened the last couple weeks with the
exception of the Denver game has been
bad no doubt about it but the fans
especially in New York you know and some
of these real rabid fan but they always
want to make a change
so like Jets fans probably said the same
thing last year now it looks like
keeping Bulls is probably gonna be a
really good move
McAdoo did go to the playoffs last year
you know and so I know what's going
wrong this year I just don't get the
sense the Giants are gonna make a rash
move during the season and honestly like
I don't see the benefit unless you're
gonna say you know well maybe we'll
promote
spaags okay well his defense is
struggled too I'm just not sure where
the answers are so where do you think
the the Black Monday spots are gonna be
now that we're we're finally getting
late early here and this
huh well you know Giants would be would
be one just to you know not saying the
definitely moves are going to happen but
you know obviously the ones were sort of
keeping an eye on you know Indy would be
another a GM finishing his first year
without the coach that he hired and see
much struggling that would certainly
make some sense you know Cleveland I
don't think they want to make a change
but the way it's gone at the least
they'll probably have to have the
conversation you know I think those are
probably those are probably the obvious
ones at this point no I'm sure I'm sure
we'll get a couple others kind of down
the stretch
so who's who's the big names that you're
hearing that that are gonna try to be
lured out of their current spots we had
Jon Gruden on Friday's show and he said
that I mean he didn't he didn't sweep it
under the rug completely and then of
course there's my guy at my alma mater
that I was always gonna have rumors
swirling around him yep
trying to come back are you hearing is
there any smoke fire what do you got for
me on those fronts yeah well I mean you
know as far as you know for Gruden I I
will say this every year you're gluten
and there's I hear the same ones this
year every year I go okay I'll I'll
believe it when I see it and I'm at that
point this year like yes he is coveted
he never wants to say no I think he
loves to be considered as you know as
everybody does I will believe it when I
see it the Harbaugh stuff there
definitely are people who know him well
who think he wants to come back to the
NFL eventually it's really just a matter
of when and you know if the coach job is
open obviously his playing history I
mean there's there's a lot of ties there
I would imagine those rumors are gonna
heat up the question is you know think
about it like Chris Ballard's uh gonna
be entering his second year picking his
first coach if you know obviously if
this happens is he gonna want to pick a
coach who then might want his own GM
that's you know that's kind of a
question I mean if you have a GM making
the hire as opposed to an owner
anyone who hires Harbaugh knows that he
may want his own GM so are you gonna
hire a coach who may end up firing you
again I I had Harbaugh on my podcast
with my wife not just sports by the way
and and he talked we talked about how he
lives next door to his parents they
watch his kids play in the backyard and
and how he enjoys campus life now you
could sit there and say well he's gonna
sit there and say I enjoy campus life
because that's what Coach is supposed to
say but when you live next door to your
folks who can have their grandkids in
for breakfast lunch dinner watch them
play in the backyard I don't know how
the Colts are the Bears could try and
replicate that I mean that's gotta count
for something Annette and that's so
different from football ik does he want
to go back to the NFL like I don't know
I mean I would guess eventually he does
considering the way it ended but the
thing with the Michigan job and the same
thing with you know hi-oh State and
Alabama there's a couple others like
those are as good as NFL jobs they
really are there's not like he needs to
prove himself on a different level like
if he likes it there he could just stay
you know didn't get himself to do it he
could just be like save and say all
right I'm going to stop moving now Ian
Rapoport of the NFL Network let's ask
you in the football question we always
ask him who's hired and fired he never
gets to act like he's an analyst on a
football show and he knows as much
football as anybody else because hired
and fired is more fun is it really
today's world kindness day Ben McAdoo
does not deserve kindness today by the
way Ben juice I looked it up in ray
Handley went 14 and 18 and he got
treated like he was the scourge of
giants of giants fandom of all time and
and Ben McAdoo just finally with that
loss yesterday went under 500 as a coach
in his career and so he's being treated
like he's very handily part - it looks
so awful as a question go hey now which
five and four team in the NFC most
likely to make the playoffs
Cowboys Falcons Lions Packers or none of
them well you got to me I would say and
I can only pick one yes that's multiple
choice in yes one Apple yeah yeah I was
never good at school I'm gonna pick the
Cowboys and I know they look terrible
yesterday obviously Tyron Smith I wasn't
he
not being there Claybourne basically
making hundreds of thousands of dollars
at their expense almost bad I believe in
the Cowboys I think they are a really
really good incapable roster even
without D Kelly and I think they're
going to go 500 over there six games
that he's out okay so I think they're
gonna be two games up with two to play
and very much in the mix Ian Rapoport
greatly appreciate it you take care
we'll see you on Thursday night Steelers
Thursday Night Football the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience